es gibt in linken intellektuellen
Kreisen massive Vorbehalte gegen Israel
weil Israel dort gesehen wird als der
apareit unterdrückerstaat der gerade
jungen PalästinenserInnen und
Palästinensern die Lebensqualität
wegnimmt die quasi dort hält das sind
natürlich Fehleinschätzungen vorurteile
Ressentiments die dort auch also schon
tradiert sind aber es hat eine
gefährliche Mischung sich jetzt ergeben
die ich immer Unsympath F mir hat immer
leid getan dass die Sympathie mit Israel
immer weniger geworden ist und das ist
in intellektuellen Kreisen auch an der
harvardun sehr weit verbreitet ist
spürbar und daher haben mich diese
Bekundungen nicht
[Musik]
überrascht